certains ont pris la route depuis
quelques jours déjà venus du nord du sud
ou de l'ouest une forme différents qu'on
voit beaucoup de voitures et de
camionnettes mais peu de poids lourds
contrairement au canada pour beaucoup de
ces manifestants la demande est clair il
exige la fin des restrictions sanitaires
avec le pass vaccinale là on peut plus
aller où on veut on peut plus faire ce
qu'on veut donc il est temps qu'on nous
rende nos libertés le mouvement n'a pas
d'organisation défini certains
manifestants milite pour un meilleur
pouvoir d'achat un enjeu qui était au
coeur des revendications des gilets
jaunes
vite élargie
ce n'est pas une revendication la
destination est la même paris
si certains sympathisants leur avait
préparé un comité d'accueil dans le sud
de la capitale atteindre la ville n'est
pas évident les entrées de la région
parisienne sont surveillés les autorités
veulent empêcher ces convois qu'elle
estime à quelques milliers de véhicules
de créer des perturbations le droit de
manifester est d'avoir une opinion est
un droit constitutionnellement garantis
dans notre public dans notre démocratie
le droit de bloquer les autres ou
d'empêcher d'aller venir de l'est pas la
préfecture de police de paris a interdit
ce type de rassemblement à bord de
véhicules pour la fin de semaine entravé
la circulation et notamment passibles de
4500 euros d'amande et de deux ans
d'emprisonnement
question d'accentuer la dissuasion plus
de 7000 policiers ont été déployés
remorques et véhicules blindés sont bien
visibles comme ici près des champs
elysées c'est le gouvernement envoie un
message de fermeté il a aussi annoncé la
levée prochaine de certaines mesures
sanitaires qui sont visés par les
contestations à la fin du mois le port
du masque ne sera plus obligatoire dans
les lieux soumis au passeport vaccinale
les autorités évoquent même une possible
levée de la vérification du statut
vaccinal au cours des prochains mois une
grande palpable des services policiers
en alerte les risques de débordement
sont présents dans un journal le
président emmanuel macron a lancé un
appel au calme question d'éviter un
regain de tension à deux mois du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
ces rappels bouvier auclair radio canada
[Musique]